Hey! How's it going bros?
My name-a-Jiyaah-Pewdiepie.
Good meme.
I've had some f--
so many fucking tech difficulties today.
I is-is-s like the twentieth time I tried to fucking do this video.
I'm really fucking excited to play the new Rick and Morty game.
I don't know why I bother doing an intro cause...
.. most likely...
.. it's just not gonna fucking work.
It-it...
.. is it working?
Okay.
I think it's working.
You see what I'm talking about?
The green screen's gonna look shit.
I'm sure the audio's gonna be shit but...
Alright, let's...
.. give it a go.
(morning sound effects)
Oh!
(water dripped on the right)
Morty: Holy crap Rick!
Pewds: Yes!
Morty: Yi-yi-yu-you made a Morty Clone, Rick!
(water drips on the right)
Pewds: Oh my god! I'm taller than (laughs softly) you.
Rick: Yeah, I know. I had to rearrange the-
Rick: -entire garage to do it.
Rick: Morty.
Pewds: (chuckles)
Pewds: This is so awesome.
(water dripped behind)
Rick: Morty clone!
Pewds: Woah!
Rick: Pay attention-
Pewds:Where did I go?
Rick: -to me.
Rick: I need you to take this laundry...
Rick: .. and put it...
Rick: .. in the washing machine.
Pewds: Is this bleach?!
Rick: There's instructions on the dry erase board.
Rick: That i put up in the garage here, the dry erase board area.
Rick: You see I wrote instructions on what you're supposed to do-
Pewds: *Pukes* AWWW! SHIT I SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT!
Pewds: My bad, let's have some more. I sound like Morty as well,
Rick and Morty: [Inaudible]
Pewds: *puking on morty* ahaha!
Morty: Crazy-
Okay we need to put the laundry, got it.
Pewds: *sniffs* Ew!
Morty: Wow Rick, he's a regular old Morty clone!
Rick: Ahh, ok good.
WELCOME WELCUM
Rick: So now that it's done the laundry, I don't need it anymore. I mean it's pretty much just a
Rick: useless pile of floating heads and hands.
Pewds: NO, NO!! *pew* AHH! What the fuck!?
*Brring* *Brring*
Oh my god, this is so cool..
Phone: Looks like you're dead, welcome to purgatory. The devil's not available so...
you get me the devil's secretary,
Pewds: What the
fuck?
Phone: We weren't actually expecting you to
be dead so soon so, if you don't want to
be dead you can just press that button right on the front of the phone.
Pewds: I can be not.. o- I'm back!!
Rick: Hey uhh, over here
Morty clone listen, uhh, had to bring you back
for some really important stuff that I
can't get into right now because me and
Morty have to go. Some stuff's gotten out of hand.
Pewds: What the fuck is happening? This is so cool.
Morty: Yeah I mean, we gotta hurry Rick, come on!
Rick: All right listen, I made a teleport
system for you. all you have to do is, you
know. Look in the direction you want to
go in the room, and then click the
trackpad button under your thumb just...
just push the button down and you can
teleport to any part of the room.
Pewds: Oh
shit... Whoa!
Rick: All right now, one last thing Morty clone.
there's a watch over there on the shelves.
I'm gonna need you to grab the watch and put
it on your wrist. You'll be able to
call me using the watch, this is very
important. All right Morty clone?
Pewds: What did
he say? This is so cool, it feels like uhh,
Job Simulator. I think it's the same
developers..
Gun: initiating Noiverse saf-
Initiating Noiverse safety. *pew pew pew*
*pew pew pew*
Pewds: Oh Shit!
Why am I doing this??? 'Cause i think this is the...
What does this do?
Ah shit shit!
some alcohol.
how drunk can you get in this game?
Yes! yes! Eww this fucking thing oh
oh this is the gayest thing I've ever
done oh my yes yes yes
oh wow shut up
now why not what's the worst thing that
can happen hey
I'm King Morty
that's
right mothafuckaaas
a fuckin sledgehammer? whoa I don't think I was
supposed to do that...
Why is it so fun to just fuck around?
Oh yeah, the watch! ok.
Rick: Oh, good! You found the watch. you're not as dumb as I thought.
dumb is like nah this is so cool I'll be
Ok use that to call me back once you get the lay of the land.
Felix: What am I supposed to do? yes! what is
this?
Mr. Meseeks! *Mr Meeseeks glitches*
Rick: I've modified the Meeseeks so you can't leave the garage.
they should mimic every action you do. except for teleporting of course.
I'm going to call them "Youseeks".
Wait I can activate a bunch of them?
EYYY IT'S ME!
MORE!
Youseek yells "I GOT IT!"
Wait, he can get it?
*Youseeks yells "THANK YOU!"*
(felix laughs)
Rick: You gotta watch out with those youseeks. they won't appear in the same place as you.
we can't have your matter intersecting with their matter in the same time and space. It's a time cop situation.
Alright clone morty, I'm gonna be receiving a part in the driveway.
R: Now since you can't leave the garage you're gonna have to use some help, so
F: *makes a youseek explode and screams*
it's the green and blue box on the shelf, that should help you out.
Even an idiot could figure this one out.
F: EW WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT
Giant Testicle: Delivery for Rick.
Ok so I can't go there but I can get the meeseeks to get it for me.
Oh that's cool! Shit, am I gonna throw it to myself? this is so fucking weird.
Catch!
*Clone Morty yelps in pain*
Ahh! what did I just touch??
*explosion in game* OHMYGOD I THINK I DID SOMETHING BAD
Rick: If you're gonna mess with it, at least use it correctly.
Whoa it's-
oh shit it's sticky! Oh! Oh no!
I broke it! :(
Rick: Oh great. they don't make them like they used to.
probably a good idea
not to order these off of Lords list.
I'm going to need you to order me another one of
these things, clone Morty.
head over to my workbench and I'll activate my
computer remotely using my remote, uh, device.
Rick: you know what they say: Hammers don't hurt people. People hurt people. hahahahaa.
what is it? let me off this is his mouse
pad ah ok we need to order what the fuck
is this porn now I don't want to get a
goddamn spam everywhere goddamn porn all
I can't be good consult the
troubleshooting guide.
repair my porn infested computer.
great how do I do that? great way to go Colin warned you broke
my computer you really have a delicate
touch we need a new fuse it's probably
down here be careful cologne morning
there's a monster down there not really
dangerous international hahaha i guess
the fuse from this thing okay
look at that the cons first portal don't
be afraid just walk through it this is
so fucking cool whoa bring significant
from up here what about your you're
pretty insignificant in you shut up but
this is so cool Jesus Christ I don't
know what to say I'm speechless this
game is so close no battery charge
batter needs to charge fuck everything
is just fucking broken
uh my microbrews machine clone morning
what the car to happen what is happening
what do I do oh my god wait i shrank I
put it there okay
what is happening sure sure sure what
that spot i'm charging it I got it yeah
yeah okay we got the battery now let's
go through the fucking Florida no wait
you don't need the part oh yeah we do
need the farm fuck how do i get the
portal again right here portal wall
got it portal battery open few i'll save
that one for later stains appears not a
problem and then last but least we need
a new ram a new ram everyone hey you
gotta ran down there he wants food give
me a metal apple and a carrot hammer
what the actual fuck are you smoking ok
I think I saw him there's a hammer good
one break good one where is the carrots
do we have carrots everyone nope that's
not it maybe in the fridge hell yeah ok
I would eat it better alright wants a
metal Apple as well not a problem sir
not a problem now let's just find some
scrap metal castle this game is so
fucking dumb I love it screwed right I
mean whatever it comes with me this is
my black hole cool here you go buddy yay
oh fuck ok all right we got the van done
yeah boy Oh gonna do nice job cold
morning try ordering that device now it
will teleport it over by the laundry
machine once you order it oh yeah that's
can also be a good place to order things
you need Oh amazon guys norfolk on Rick
part wanted by it
chart shows to Jerry Smith oh shit it
there yeah Oh what thank God you got the
part okay took you long enough oh the
part you're holding is of critical
importance you're going to use it to
retrieve an extremely powerful item it's
not going to be easy it's going to be
one of the hardest things I've ever done
and be very confusing it's going to be
very difficult it's going to be really
challenging this shit is about to get
kicked up like 100 notches and when
you're ready for the part of your life
give me a call back on the florists
comment that I made by today okay we got
to gear up mr. horse I want that
painting so bad it's fucking amazing
alright sounds like we're gonna have to
gear up properly I'm gonna have to make
the most deadliest weapon of all time
cucumber hammer I'm ready well that's
all the time you needed to prepare for
your impending them for you in the
portal just correct a new location with
the arrows on the portal ball ever and
then show once you collected it pull the
lever and a portal will open up
automatically for you you're gonna want
to grab the device you but on the
internet you can want to bring that with
you okay ready okay here we go oh where
the fuck am I oh this one is very
challenging part of the team attach the
device to the bottom of the plunger
bottom of the one over and I'm so cool
why am I doing this Gary if the toilet
doesn't flush stop crying great the fuck
is it like maximum better I really do it
you know your Christmas shit hahaha oh
my god they brush my teeth
I don't know why I tried this obviously
it's not interesting okay snail day now
what way to go look it up for you Nick
goes in the bank you know I mean at the
plunger weird up under you can we go
there we go what's the fuck is Rick game
like toilets broken right you can work
again open the toilet tank make sure
there's liquid in the time okay well
there's the wine is how rich people and
have the bathroom the fuck is it what is
this good job Lori I told Lori you know
to use the bathtub to deposit that thing
but sit on the toilet then we have to
grab it now we have it rabbit and head
back to the portal are you fucking
kidding me this is what I came for
I'm collecting shit that's what a fuck
where do you come on Morty you're
finally back from your little bathroom
adventure listen I mean operating the
car for a very important outing whoa get
into right now anyways I'm going to need
you to plug the seed into that seed
shaped hole in the engine area okay oh
there haha mega seed artificial
intelligence microprocessor fucking
we're good we're gonna need some help
upgrading this car since you can't talk
go ahead and call me on your watch thing
you know the thing on your wrist about
oh okay all right you're ready to go huh
all right I'm gonna need your help to
upgrade the rest of the car hey Rick
how's the clone suppose to know how to
fix the car you know I mean it's just a
dumb clone one of the instructions are
simple Yeah right Rick I think you
couldn't figure it out shut up Morty all
right we got this fucking thing whatever
it does contains engine to repair manual
otherwise what do I do with it
Oh
what that fuck is it so weird oops why
do I feel like I'm not fucking bitch I
don't think this calls gonna be able to
figure it out I mean this is a really
complicated one it's very simple that
videos read the instructions they'd
figure it out yeah you know but I don't
know man I don't I mean we could be here
for a while you know what it is easy
even you could figure it out Rick I'll
figure something out I figured up you're
an asshole right Morty just quit quit
quit bitching it out for fuck sake
that's the way everywhere that's an
upgrade huh what do you call that
fuckery incorrect combination please try
a little harder that's an upgrade ha ha
ha ha what the fuck all right I can do
this if it's this one it doesn't fucking
work unless there's no red ok which one
it's not it's a this one then there has
to be two red which it can't be because
it can have one link with no duplicate
more than one so it can't be this one
if it's this one same thing
my missing some
I think I'm missing one way I think I
got it oh my god yeah interconnect why
did I take me so fucking long oh my god
I'm a fucking idiot what now what now
not more please got another fucking
battery well I guess it's time to do
this again
but there's more of them now like a
weird Simon Says game it's kind of fun
box fuck the distress in the ass fuck
fuck shut up you're kidding me no I was
so calm
really fucking gun okay you got your new
battery fully charged to microbrews yes
all connected I hoped I came from a
conflict-free micro no Dark Matter tank
where the fuck did I get that hey you
ducked it a morning catch hahaha is that
a Pepsi it's a black fish I love
laughing where'd you go I am the car I
made a mixtape to what your mixtape
stuff mine is better okay that's why my
teeth has no music on it great catch a
are more personal for you I think I just
blew it up I gotta throw it haha stupid
clone Morty okay
we're gonna have to get a mr. music
throw it over there oh we're gonna have
to give it to myself oh oh this is so
cool oh my god are you serious come on
mr. meeseeks little further now oh I'm
starting really close to the life that's
it no fuck you're useless I almost just
fucking died okay it's not funny almost
there almost there
yes yes is it go it in I can't tell is
it go yes all right morning summer it
looks like the car is ready to go so
let's get rolling the gets hit to do
Michael Murray he just rolled today so
kudos to you it would just take some
time to relax but you can it's a
dangerous thing yeah damn it see my
fucking head Jesus Christ all right
really cool game I really enjoy it but
fucking in smash that like button and
I'll see you bros in the next video
thank you so much for watching
*BROFIST*